[Musique]
tout ce matin la dépouille du pape
Benoît XVI a été transportée à la
basilique Saint-Pierre de Rome
2 rouges la couleur du deuil papa un
chapelet entre les mains il sera exposé
en chapelle ardente jusqu'à mercredi des
milliers de personnes des fils devant
son cercueil certains se prennent même
en photo
à l'extérieur le fil est interminable de
nombreux fidèles veulent lui rendre un
dernier hommage je l'ai connu
personnellement en 2006 il avait la
visite adlimina de mes évêques et nous
sommes allés à la dans la maison des
Papes et il n'a pas suivi le protocole
avec moi il a commencé à parler avec moi
ça dépassait le temps il m'a posé des
questions sur ma vie à l'université à 5
Anselme Benoît 16 la profondément
marquée devenu pape en 2005 l'allemand
josé fradinières a renoncé à ses
fonctions en 2013 pour des raisons de
santé avant de s'éteindre samedi à l'âge
de 95 ans une théologie de renom basée
sur les Pères de l'Église et puis un
homme de de vie concrète de simplicité
évangélique
je suis très ému ce prêtre de la Zambie
c'était un grand pape
sur la place Saint-Pierre les curieux et
les touristes sont aussi de la partie on
est en vacances à Rome là pour quelques
jours donc effectivement on est venu
visiter ce beau monument et du coup bah
rendre hommage aussi au pape décidé par
la même occasion ce matin
cette résidence de Rome un moment qui
unit les gens dans la foi
les funérailles de Benoît XVI seront
célébrés jeudi par son successeur le
pape François une première dans
l'histoire de l'Église catholique ici
Olivier Bachard Radio-Canada Montréal